quand deux roues en ga au kurdistan
irakien
quinze mille réfugiés yézidie vif ici
dans le plus grand dénuement
cette minorité religieuse a été
persécuté par des ch
parmi les réfugiés on trouve de nombreux
enfants comme ayad
le garçon a vécu en captivité sul état
islamique
jusqu'à sa libération à l'été 2016 il
n'a que 12 ans lorsqu'il est envoyé dans
un camp d'entraînement militaire du
groupe terroriste pour devenir enfant
soldat
le matin on été réveillé à 4 heures on
devait faire nos ambitions et la prière
après on lisait quelques versets du
coran et ensuite il nous emmenait à
l'entraînement ils nous ont appris à
poser des explosifs
la leçon était rapide ils nous ont dit
avec les bombes
la première erreur est aussi la dernière
ayad a été malgré lui l'acteur d'une
vidéo de propagande film et à ar raqqa
fief syrien de l'état islamique
machinalement l'enfant se met à
fredonner les champs de ses bourreaux
[Musique]
m
là on apprend à s'engouffrer dans les
tunnels comme ça quand l'aviation
ennemie bombarde on est protégé et les
éclats d'obus ne peuvent pas nous
toucher ces mois-là ici à l'entraînement
ils nous battaient avec des câbles
électriques
si on n'avait pas bien retenu la leçon
ils tiraient tous prennent au pied pour
nous mettre la pression
après des mois d'entraînement à iad est
emmené au front pour combattre son
propre peuple
les forces kurdes tu as fini par croire
en eux après cette formation
non mais eux ils disaient qu'ils
allaient conquérir le monde
je me disais que même si je parvenais à
fuir il arriverait à me retrouver et à
me ramener étaient nombreux et moi
j'étais tout seul du coup j'étais obligé
je suis devenu comme
[Musique]
ayad souhaite aujourd'hui oublier ce
passé et retrouver sa mère réfugié en
allemagne des enfants comme ayad il y en
aurait des milliers
nous allons vous raconter l'histoire de
adiyiah salé et christina l'histoire des
enfants perdus du califat en juin 2014
l'état islamique lance une vaste
offensive et s'empare d'une partie de
l'irak et de la syrie il y instaure un
califat sa zone d'influencé à cheval sur
les deux pays
ces temps de mossoul à jaca sur un
territoire aussi vaste que la grande
bretagne 7 millions d'habitants
[Musique]
pour asseoir son royaume de la terreur
des champs brigade la jeunesse et créer
une nouvelle génération de djihadistes
des enfants soldats
ap les lionceaux dressé pour tuer ces
images filmées par l'organisation
diffusée sur internet servent sa
propagande
cet endoctrinement à grande échelle en
vue de créer un homme nouveau rappel
celui du troisième reich
les jeunesses hitlériennes étaient alors
un rouage essentiel de l'entreprise
totalitaire nazi endoctrinés mais aussi
persécutés au coeur du califat les
enfants issus des minorités religieuses
chrétiennes et yézidie sont victimes de
crimes de guerre dénoncé dès 2015
dans ce rapport des nations unies
sur son territoire l'état islamique se
prête à un trafic sexuel de grande
ampleur des centaines d'enfants sont
vendus et exploiter nous sommes allés à
la rencontre des combattants de l'ombre
ceux qui luttent et dénonce les
exactions de dèche
sagnet est là est-ce que la vierge 11 12
ans ce prix onze mille dollars lieu jaca
des résistants comme bach zad mènent des
opérations d'exfiltration pour sauver
ces victimes là c'est akram
on a déjà sauvé sa petite soeur de six
ans grâce à lui des familles parviennent
à retrouver leurs enfants des revenants
que des médecins et psychologues
essayent par la suite de soigner jumana
on parle de ça joumana cet homme se
faisait peur la nuit où la journée
qu'adviendra-t-il de cette génération
perdue des enfants de cette taille il en
remettait des ceintures vous avez vu ça
oui et ça a pesé pour le corps ses
enfants doivent-ils être puni juger ou
soigner
sont ils des victimes ou des bourreaux
[Musique]
décembre dernier nous nous rendons dans
le nord de l'irak
en pleine bataille de mossoul
depuis deux mois l'armée irakienne tente
de libérer la ville capitale
autoproclamée du califat et ils livrent
des combats féroces contre des ch
[Musique]
nous partons vers les quartiers repris
récemment à l'organisation terroriste à
l'est de mossoul
plus loin plus loin du but de nous
ouvrir la voie dans les rangs ennemis
les soldats nous affirme devoir parfois
combattre des enfants
les fameux lionceaux du califat
[Musique]
à points actuellement il y a des enfants
qui participe à la bataille de mossoul
contre nous dans les rangs de dèche
ils ont quel âge ils ont entre 10 et 15
ans pas plus
des chants vois des enfants se faire
sauter contre nous trou mener des
attentats suicide
comment vous pouvez savoir que ce sont
des enfants
ça se voit un jeune sans barbe c'est
qu'il est encore enfant ou ado regardez
il ya des carcasses de voitures piégées
par des shs celle là le kamikaze est
encore dedans on peut descendre fils
mais non impossible aux mains de neige
depuis plus de deux ans la ville est la
vitrine du système totalitaire établi
surtout le califat dans son ambition
affichée de créer un homme nouveau
le groupe terroriste à cibler en
priorité les enfants et donc l'école
en 2015 le ministère de l'éducation du
groupe terroriste et mais un décret à
l'attention de toutes les écoles
collèges et facultés un document dans
lequel il définit sa politique
doivent être supprimées des programmes
d'enseignement les matières suivantes la
philosophie les sciences sociales la
musique le dessin le sport la
psychologie et l'histoire ne pas
enseigner le concept de nationalisme ou
de patriotisme le remplacer par celui de
l'appartenance à l'islam
supprimer des matières scientifiques
toute allusion à la théorie de darwin
dieu a créé l'homme tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui des directives appliquée
dans un collège où nous nous rendons
aujourd'hui désertés auparavant aux
mains de des ch
le gardien de l'établissement nous sert
de guide
les militaires sont anxieux
l'organisation a piégé de nombreux
bâtiments
c'est bon pas de mine
t'es sur qui a pas de danger tiens
y'avait un cadavre là et à laitages
dèche avait posté des snipers dans le
bureau du directeur
le sol est jonché de manuels scolaires
deux modestes fascicule en noir et blanc
les dernières disciplines toléré par des
ch ce sont des petits livres
c'est la chimie oui hélas il ya les
maths et là il ya la biologie des
matières largement expurgé en biologie
par exemple pas de représentation de
corps humains des enseignements réduit à
quelques pages pour des écoles devenu en
réalité des centres de recrutement comme
en témoignent ses enfants du quartier
le renseignement étaient nuls ils l'ont
frappé
il vous enseigner quoi une balle plus
une balle égale de balle et quoi d'autre
une bombe puisse une bombe égal de
bombes
arar il disait le diable a à faire le
djihad ça veut dire faire la guerre il
disait venez vous battre dans les rangs
de l'état islamique
nous sommes ici pour toujours du coup on
a arrêté d'aller à l'école la guerre
comme matière d'apprentissage et ce dès
le plus jeune âge
nous avons retrouvé des manuels de neige
destinés à l'enseignement primaire en
mathématiques des pistolets pour
apprendre à compter et en anglais un
exercice d'écriture agrémenté d'une
kalachnikov et dans lequel l'élève doit
reproduire des mots comme armé ou balle
aux abords de mossoul dans le camp de
réfugiés de cazères nous rencontrons un
instituteur arrivée du front cinq jours
auparavant il a travaillé six mois sous
l'état islamique
avant de demander son départ à la
retraite horrifiée par l'enseignement
imposé par les djihadistes
regardez là ce sont des mathématiques
pour ce ces exercices existait avant
l'arrivée de dèche des exercices
classiques de classement par taille ou
pardon mais eux ils ont remplacé les
objets par des mitrailleuses des épées
des pistolets des avions c'est une
catastrophe pour les enfants un pistolet
vous avez remarqué mon petit bien demain
theron pour dire un pistolet cet enfant
ne devrait pas reconnaître ces choses là
il naissance et à son âge connaître que
la banane la pomme déjouer c'est une
arme automatique
une bkc
il enseignait aux jeunes élèves le
nombre de balles et il les entraînait au
tir comme discipline sportive
une fois elles ont même enseigne et ça à
mon fils à l'école les enfants ont été
mentalement imprégné par cette idéologie
pour les influencer des chats développer
l'ignorance mais pas seulement
l'ignorance l'intimidation la terreur
les crimes les décapitations qu'athènes
les cadavres exposés dans la vraie la
rue c'est bien là que des chaumes et hop
à toute une génération
il y a quelques mois nous avions pu
contacter un membre du réseau clandestin
jaca meurent en silence
un groupe d'activistes qui dénonce
depuis le fief syrien de l'état
islamique les exactions du groupe
terroriste au péril de leur vie à l'eau
je vous recevoir l'un de nous avait
alors confirmé la prise en otage de la
jeunesse bardèche l'organisation a mis
en place une politique d'engagement des
petits dans les rues ils leur donnent
des sucreries des jouets pour les
aborder
ils leur font l'apologie du djihad en
leur disant regarde nous portons des
armes
toi aussi tu peux en avoir tes parents
te dis ce que tu es encore un enfant
pourquoi tu ne viens pas combattre avec
lou pour devenir un héros
tu ne veux pas mener une opération
suicide et devenir un martyr
la propagande est partout comme en
témoignent ces images tournées par des
chants 2015 ces hommes recrute jusqu'aux
abords des parcs d'attraction des bus
sillonnent les villes du califat pour
embrigader toujours plus de lionceaux on
les appelle les caravanes de la
prédication les jeunes handicapés ne
peuvent y échapper et l'organisation
utilise même des enfants pour enrôler
d'autres enfants pour compléter son
apologie de la guerre sainte
des shows organise aussi ce qu'il
appelle des points presse
des écrans géants installés dans les
rues sur lesquels sont diffusés des
vidéos de combats ou d'exécution ce jour
là celle de la mise à mort d'un pilote
jordanien brûlés vifs
tu as vu la vidéo wii qu'est ce que tu
en penses
je suis très heureux pourquoi parce
qu'ils l'ont brûlée si j'avais pu je
leur ait brûlé moi même j'espère qu'on
en brûlera d'autres biberonné aux
horreurs à 10 est un autre activiste de
jaca il a fait le tour du califat sous
une fausse identité avant de fuir la
région
selon lui des chutes y lisent les
enfants comme délateur et s'immisce dans
la cellule familiale pour mieux la
détruire
ils ont des brigades spécialisées en
charge de propager l'idéologie de neige
parmi les jeunes les parents ne peuvent
plus exercer leur pouvoir sur leurs
enfants un père ne peut pas dire à son
fils que des choses ce sont des
terroristes ou des monstres car il ne
peut pas être certain que son enfant
n'ira pas rapporter ça aux membres de
l'organisation qu'il n'ira pas le
raconter mon père dit que vous êtes des
terroristes
ce genre de choses a eu lieu plusieurs
fois jaca et cela a fini par l'exécution
du père coupés de leurs familles
endoctrinés il ne restait plus à des
chocs à faire de ces enfants de jeunes
soldats une arme et des exécutants
dociles de tueur impitoyable
[Musique]
fin 2015 dèche met en scène une sorte de
jeu télévisé dans un décor qui rappelle
fort boyard six enfants se voit confier
une mission exécuté des prisonniers
ligoté et cachés dans des tunnels une
production hollywoodienne pour signifier
à l'ennemi que la nouvelle génération
est opérationnel parmi ces six garçons
salman alcine jarry un liesi de 8 ans
entraînée comme les autres à toutes les
méthodes d'exécution
brochot perdre ou et les juifs salman
finira par décapité sa victime
l'image de l'enfant bourreau fera le
tour du monde sur internet
alimentant la communication de dèche
[Musique]
une image qui hantent l'oncle de salmane
nous l'avons retrouvée au kurdistan
il souhaite garder l'anonymat vous
pouvez vous l'identifier oui c'est lui
le petit était on se dit qu'en daschle a
pris un enfant est sensible et
intelligent tout petit déjà il était
responsable il aider son père à
l'épicerie ils les ont forcés à tuer les
pauvres choux 4 à 3 ils ont peur
[Musique]
salman a été contraint de choisir entre
tuer ou mourir il y a un an
il est parvenu à joindre sa famille
réfugiée en zone libre
vous lui avez parlé au téléphone
oui deux fois que disait-il pour les
revenir mais personne n'a pu l'exfiltrer
aujourd'hui on n'a plus aucune nouvelle
de lui
selon nos informations
salman serait toujours en vie aux mains
de dèche sur son territoire
l'état islamique fabrique une génération
d'assassin et instaure la banalité du
mal dans le camp de réfugiés de charia
au kurdistan irakien
nous allons découvrir que des shs
poussent les enfants au meurtre
même en dehors des terrains de guerre ou
de ses films de propagande
[Musique]
cette fratrie à étaient captives de dh
avec sa mère pendant deux ans victime de
violences et de simulacres d'exécution
fadi adia et chadi ont dû un jour tu es
à leur tour gratuitement le condamné à
mort l'heure est à mener ligotées et les
yeux bandés par un joli et djihadistes
il est venu et nous a dit toi tu coupes
un pied toi tu couper un bras
et toi tu frappes le visage au couteau
sinon je vous enlève tous les trois à
votre mère et je vous tue qu'as tu
ressenti pourquoi tu l'as fait on a eu
peur de dire non nous ont donné à chacun
une machette
moi je devais couper la main j'ai coupé
la main lui il a dû couper les pieds et
chadi il lui a donné des coups de
couteau au visage
moi je vais couper le pied
ma soeur lui a coupé la main et xavi lui
a planté des coups de couteau au niveau
de la bouche
à quels endroits au niveau de la figure
il était conscient en vie c'est quand
chadi lui a donné un coup de couteau
dans les yeux qu'il est mort un récit
glaçant corroborée par la mer en
apparence détacher les trois enfants
portent en eux les séquelles de leur
passage aux mains de dèche chadi le
petit dernier est le plus perturbé
devenus diabétiques
il se comporte de façon violente et
dangereuse un jour j'ai dit a mis un
couteau sur la gorge de notre plus
petite soeur il lui aurait sûrement des
coupé l'oreille les ma mère est arrivée
à temps il a empêché
on lui a dit qu'est ce que tu fais avec
ce couteau et il a répondu je vais
l'égorger m'appartient une autre fois il
a failli mettre le feu à notre tente ma
petite soeur était endormi il y avait de
la fumée qui s'échappe et moi je les
gifler mais il m'a mis un gros coup de
bâton et ça a fait boum dans ma tête il
a dit faut brûler cet endroit comme
daraîche
pour
malgré ses troubles du comportement la
fratrie vite ici depuis un an sans
réelle prise en charge psychologique
les trois frères et soeurs étaient
parvenus à fuir miraculeusement le
califat mais certains enfants forcés à
franchir la ligne entre le bien et le
mal
n'en sont eux jamais revenu comme ses
deux frères mise en scène dans une des
vidéos diffusées récemment par des shs
assad 12 ans et amjad 13 ans les voici
avant leur capture
chacun au volant d'une voiture bourrée
d'explosifs il s'apprête à mener deux
opérations kamikazes
c'est yézidie convertis de force menace
jusqu'à leur famille
nous souhaitons frapper les ennemis de
dieu
mais faire exploser même si ce sont nos
propres parents si dieu le veut nous
allons frapper les mécréants les
opérations sont filmés au drone la mort
des deux adolescents ressemble un jeu
vidéo
la cible des chars de l'armée irakienne
[Musique]
c'était à mossoul
en janvier dernier avec la reprise de
territoires sous contrôle de dèche
une question se pose au libérateur que
faire des jeunes les considérer comme
coupable ou comme victime
par mesure de sécurité dans les camps
aux abords de mossoul la population
rescapés des combats est maintenue en
isolement
les réfugiés notamment les jeunes hommes
restent suspects aux yeux des autorités
qui craignent l'infiltration d'éléments
terroristes
c'est mon neveu
pourquoi vous ne pouvez pas sortir je ne
peux pas et n'accepte pas pourquoi
je ne sais pas des adolescents suspectés
de liens avec des ch ont été arrêtées
dans ce camp certains ont été envoyés en
détention à kirkouk à 180km de mossoul
l'ombre de dèche plane sur la ville une
violente attaque du groupe terroriste
deux mois avant notre arrivée en
décembre dernier a fait 92 morts
dans une prison tenue secrète nous
rencontrons un adolescent qui a reconnu
son adhésion à l'état islamique noises à
12 ans lorsqu'il s'engage aux côtés de
dèche
après que l'organisation est envahi le
village musulman où il réside
entraînez est envoyé au front le jeune
soldat perçoit même un salaire mensuel
de 50 euros
il parle aujourd'hui sous le contrôle de
ses geôliers je n'ai jamais tiré
je n'ai jamais tué j'étais juste de
garde dans les tranchées et tu penses
que tu es innocent non je ne suis pas
innocent pourquoi pas ce que j'ai fait
partie d'eux je ne recommencerai plus
j'ai beaucoup de remords j'ai prêté
allégeance
mais lorsque je suis entré dans leurs
rangs et que j'ai vu ce qui se passe là
bas j'ai regretté j'ai compris que ce
n'était pas l'islam
j'ai compris combien ils avaient tort
toi tu les a rejoints par conviction oui
moi j'étais convaincu et on perd aussi
été convaincu oui mon père mon frère mon
oncle mon père a été tué par un raid
aérien au village de hass inch'allah vie
et mon frère
il est mort au combat à résilles à quel
âge avait ton frère mon frère il avait
18 ans ils ont démoli la vie ils ont
détruit mon père mon frère mon oncle ma
famille je n'ai plus de famille à part
mon grand frère il est enfermé dans
cette prison avec moi
remords de circonstance ou regret
sincère
nul ne peut le dire pour les autorités
mourad reste un soldat ennemi aller
lève-toi 750 mineurs sont aujourd'hui
emprisonnés en irak
beaucoup attendent leur jugement
mais il est impossible à
l'administration de les relâcher car
certains constituent toujours une menace
[Musique]
en août dernier à quelques rues de la
prison un enfant de neuf ans est arrêté
une ceinture d'explosifs sur lui ne
filmez pas ne filmaient pas ça peut tout
faire sauter des policiers parviennent à
la désamorcer
le jeune kamikaze va alors évité de
justesse un lâchage par la foule
éloignez vous éloignez vous reculez
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît monsieur ne me fait pas
mal mais pas peur n'aie pas peur mais
ferait reculer laisser le jeu vous
emplit reculé de minutes le candidat ou
martyrs venue de mossoul attend
aujourd'hui son jugement en prison
quelques semaines après cette
arrestation
son frère parviendra à se faire exploser
une quarantaine d'attentats suicide
auraient été perpétrés en irak par des
enfants depuis sa conquête du califat en
déj s'est rendu coupable de nombreux
crimes contre les minorités religieuses
considéré comme mécréante notamment d'
esclavage sexuel sur les enfants
kristina à trois ans lorsqu'elle est
arraché à sa mère aida leur village est
alors occupée et la population
chrétienne et déportés dans des bus des
rafles qui rappelle la seconde guerre
mondiale la donne dans le bus ils nous
ont dit qu'ils nous emmenait un
dispensaire pour nous examiner et
soigner ceux qui avaient des problèmes
de santé mais c'était faux ils n'ont
rien fait tout ça
ils étaient tous vêtus de noir au moment
du tri ils ont dépossédé ceux qui
avaient de l'argent ou de l'or nous
sommes remontés dans leur bus
nous nous sommes pauvres nous n'avions
rien à donner
alors ils ont pris notre petite fille
depuis
eide a obtenu des nouvelles son enfant
est aux mains d'un djihadiste de 70 en
filmant à mossoul
il y a quelques mois elle a même
retrouvé une photo de christina sur un
site de dèche qui se vante de ses prises
chrétienne elle est jolie mais c'est une
enfant
quel intérêt de la retenir peut-être
qu'ils attendent qu'elles grandissent
pour la prendre pour femmes mais
j'espère que cela ne se réalisera jamais
si dieu le veut
si jamais elle revient j'espère qu'elle
nous aura pas oublié
je ne crois pas mata christina est une
enfant si intelligente je ne pensais pas
qu'elle m'oublieras
aïda se rend au camp de cazères à une
heure de route
un des plus grands à la périphérie de
mossoul
des dizaines de milliers de réfugiés
viennent d'y arriver
fuyant les combats aïda espère obtenir
de nouvelles informations
peut-être même y retrouver sa fille
le camp est grand si grand des photos de
christina quelques indications et un
numéro de téléphone pour contacter les
parents mais dans un camp qui compte
cent mille personnes les chances d'aïda
sont minces au nom du père du fils et du
saint-esprit ma chérie mon dieu qu'elle
revienne
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour c'est ma fille sur cette
photo monsieur si elle arrive dans ce
camp mais elle est perdue des shsh la
capture et que dieu maudisse dèche aïda
craint pour la vie de sa fille
les avions de la coalition killen
mossoul depuis des semaines
quelle est la situation dans mossoul
catastrophique vraiment les
bombardements ça ça bombarde beaucoup
hier ils ont ramené plein de blessés moi
j'ai une petite fille kidnappée à
l'intérieur les garçons et les amène au
combat mais les petites filles ne les
tue pas un jour les délits schiste ont
emmené une fillette de trois ans belle
et toute blonde mais l'été yézidie et
une adolescente yézidie aussi mais elle
elle s'est immolé par le feu
vous savez ce qu'ils font aux fillettes
il les élève quand elles atteignent 9 10
ans ils les épouses moi j'étais là
voyons dans la mire un jour il a amené
une otage de 15 ans et l'épousé alors
qu'il a 35 ans et récemment il a apporté
une fillette de trois ans et il a dit
qu'il l'a marierait à son fils qui a 6
ans
aidez-moi je vous en supplie à ce jour
christina est toujours captif dans
mossoul au coeur des combats dans les
derniers quartiers encore aux mains de
des ch
des filles est kidnappé exploité es
mariée de force
quelle est la réalité de ce trafic
sexuel à 80km de mossoul à erbil
capitale du kurdistan
nous avons rendez vous avec un témoin
clé
il tient à rester anonyme mais ils
enquêtent sur ce phénomène depuis des
mois et a recueilli de nombreuses
preuves
une de ces sources a réussi à fuir le
califat avec deux portables de
djihadistes dans les téléphones
notre contact a découvert de véritables
marchés aux esclaves sur des groupes de
discussion des centaines de jihadistes
achètent ou vendent des mineurs à partir
de 6 ans par exemple l'un se djihadistes
annonce salle une esclave déflorer à
vendre 13 ans corps mince rend son
travail elle nettoie et lave sans
rechigner religion dit converti à
l'islam a commencé à apprendre le coran
le prix 9000 $ et la esclaves vierge
11 12 ans free onze mille dollars lieu
raquin les maquis comme ça pour les
vendre plus vite et plus cher car ce
sont des ventes aux enchères
ça commence à 10 mille dollars par
exemple des djihadistes peuvent
renchérir 200 ou 500 dollars et ainsi de
suite jusqu'à ce qu'elles soient vendues
de bois
sur un marché virtuel intitulé call if
i'm all nous trouvons même des messages
audio envoyé par un vendeur et un
acheteur indécis l'homme déploie son
argumentaire commercial comme s'il
s'agissait d'un quelconque produit
[Musique]
salut l'ami l'esclave et déflorer mais
elle a 14 ans sa beauté 70 sur 100 et
même plus depuis son esclavage elle n'a
été vendu que deux fois
il comprend elle n'est pas passée entre
les mains de trop deux frères un de nos
frères l'a eu pour un certain temps et
le second apparemment il ne l'aurait
même pas touché pas pénétrer ce n'est
pas sûr mais je peux m'en assurer pour
toi ces pratiques sont officiellement
encouragée par l'état islamique
l'exploitation sexuelle de mineurs et
même encadrée par les tribunaux de dèche
sous couvert de mariage dont l'âge légal
est fixé à 9 ans
mais ici une acquisition pose problème
la fillette n'a que 7 ans l'acheteur
semble ennuyer
quel âge alain sept ans mais elle est
encore trop jeune pour les 7000 $
demandés
c'est vrai mais elle a déjà ses règles
rial a des poils pubiens
ps si elle a des poils pubiens pour eux
c'est un critère de sélection
cela veut dire qu'elle est prête pour le
sexe pour la population même si elle a
moins de 9 ans oui même si elle a moins
de 9 ans si un combattant on va au
tribunal et prouve qu'une petite de
moins de 9 ans à ses premiers signes de
puberté
le tribunal lui donne le droit d'avoir
des rapports sexuels ou de la vendre
face à l'horreur qui frappe son peuple
un jeune yézidie barzakh farhan s'est
mobilisé avec un groupe de volontaires
pour exfiltrer ses enfants otages
[Musique]
ça ce sont les affaires d'une rescapée
capturé à l'âge de 16 ans quand est
arrivée en zone libre
elle portait sa niqab islamique
tout objet qui vient de là bas je le
récupère le classe et le prend en photo
dans le futur m je veux utiliser ses
affaires pour créer un musée pour qu'on
n'oublie pas les horreurs que ses filles
et ses enfants ont subi
celui qu'on surnomme le libérateur
sauf des mineurs et recense les crimes
de guerre de dèche réduits en esclavage
les yézides y ont également été victimes
d'une véritable tentative génocidaire
sur les murs des listes de noms
interminable
regardez ça ce sont des enfants enfin
enfin enfin enfin plus de 2000 enfants
ont été victimes deux dash pris en otage
mort en fuyant ou tués dans des
exécutions massives camp qu'ils avaient
plus de 15 ans l'étrier avant de les
tuer si les gamins avait des poils sous
les aisselles
ça voulait dire qu'ils étaient des
hommes et donc en âge de mourir depuis
l'an dernier
barrada exfiltrer une cinquantaine
d'enfants grâce à un réseau de
résistants au coeur du califat les
opérations peuvent nécessiter des mois
d'enquêté
témoignage plans photos
les familles sont souvent dispersés un
puzzle dont bach zad s'efforce de
rassembler les morceaux
c'est un exemple de chami disséminés aux
quatre coins du califat les parents sont
portées disparues voilà une de leurs
filles elles et à deir ezzor en syrie
[Musique]
selon des informations récentes
elle a été mise en vente pour être marié
ça c'est son frère akram
elle a 9 ans il est à jaca en syrie
utilisée comme esclave domestique
[Musique]
grièvement blessé par des chutes lors de
sa capture en 2014
akram a été acheté à 3000 dollars moins
cher que d'autres petits garçons puisque
incapable d'aller au combat
barzani essaye actuellement de
l'arracher des griffes de l'état
islamique
voici leur petite soeur jumana l assise
aux ailes et esclaves à mossoul deux
semaines après notre rencontre la petite
jumana été exfiltrés par le réseau de
bars zad
elle a été accueillie par des cousins
éloignés dans le camp de kabar tôt près
de dohouk
[Musique]
sa mère a été assassinée par des ch pour
s'être rebellé contre le traitement fait
à ses enfants jumana refuse d'aller à
l'école et ne cesse de parler de sexe
ses proches sont persuadés qu'elle a été
abusée un cousin l'emmène voir une
psychothérapeute une prise en charge
gratuite
une fois par mois c'est la première fois
qu'il s'y rendent
elle a tenté de se suicider plusieurs
fois parfois elle quitte la tente même
en pleine nuit et ne revient pas on la
ramène de force
elle a des comportements violents avec
les enfants des voisins
comment elle a essayé de se suicider par
le feu en s'immolant mal ce centre
médical reçoit quotidiennement des
enfants rescapés de l'enfer de dèche
quand tu seras que doctor who tu diras
bien que tu as mal que tu es triste
parce que tu as perdu tes parents à
l'erreur histoire c'est impoli
tu lui expliquera que tu as été kidnappé
bonjour bienvenue je suis le docteur
gall avait dans la main au dr
comment vas-tu bien tu vas bien elle a
peur la nuit elle parle de choses seuls
les enfants que voit cette
psychothérapeute présentent tous un état
de stress post traumatique jumana comme
les autres peinent à exprimer sa
souffrance
mais son comportement et ses dessins
parle pour elle tu veux les couvrir tu
veux qu'ils soient cachés ils ont peur
de quoi jouent mal ils ont peur ou bien
honte barre des navets joumana on parle
de sa jument jumana cet homme te faisait
peur la nuit où la journée je veux m'en
aller
un deck l'expression du visage reflète
de la terreur
les yeux se sont écarquillés et les bras
sont ouverts et en l'air c'est un appel
au secours
en fait cet enfant est revenu dans un
état critique
il est évident qu'ils lui ont fait subir
des choses très graves si ces choses ne
lui ont pas été faites à elle
directement des viols ont dû se passer
sous ses yeux sur d'autres enfants où
elle a dû subir elle même ces choses
horribles
qu'adviendra-t-il de ces revenants
encore hanté par le califat pour se
reconstruire
peu ont accès à une prise en charge
psychologique
au kurdistan les victimes sont trop
nombreuses et les moyens modestes
orpheline accueillis par une famille
démunie rejeté par ses camarades
la guérison de joumana risque d'être
longue
pour d'autres l'avenir s'annonce un peu
moins sombre pour aider ces enfants
yézidie rescapés l'allemagne a mis en
place un programme d'accueil unique en
europe
ayad l'adolescent enrôlé par des ch va
en bénéficier
après six mois passés dans ce camp de
réfugiés il part pour stuttgart où ont
déjà été rapatriés son petit frère et sa
mère
je suis triste parce que je vais quitter
ma terre l'irak et je suis heureux parce
que je vais retrouver ma mère mes amis
et ma famille j'ai perdu mon enfance
c'était trop tous ses malheurs et tous
ces problèmes pour un enfant pour
quelqu'un d'aussi jeune que moi c'était
vraiment trop j'étais heureux dans ma
vie d'avant mais j'ai perdu mon enfance
bien que je t'embrasse ayad fait ses
adieux à ses cousins pas ce bonjour à la
famille
il va enfin retrouver sa mère qu'il n'a
pas vu depuis deux ans
et
à 14 ans ayad à la maturité de ceux qui
ont connu l'enfer s'ils s'envole vers un
avenir qu'il espère meilleur le passé
continue de l'habiter
ce sera impossible d'oublier ce qui
m'est arrivé
ils m'ont fait beaucoup de mal et à la
société toute entière aussi les
prochaines générations n'oublieront pas
cette catastrophe et ses massacres les
jours et les mois ont passé et
personnellement je dirais qu'il reste en
moi 40 à 50% de ce passé qui va pouvoir
t'en débarrasser
c'est le futur qui le déterminera selon
les circonstances le futur le dira
[Musique]
deux ans en école sans parents formé à
tuer haïr les ennemis de dèche jusqu'à
sa propre mère qu'il traitait de
mécréante lorsqu'elle la plaie en
cachette pour le supplier de fuir dèche
aujourd'hui il lui parle avec tendresse
salut maman ça va je vais bien chez toi
ça va merci on va prendre l'avion et on
arrive dans trois quatre heures chez
vous accompagne allez bye bye chose un
au revoir en allemand comme pour
signifier sa mère sa joie de la
rejoindre
après des heures de vol et de trajet en
train ayad atteint enfin sa destination
finale à stuttgart
il y est attendu par sa mère et son
frère
les services sociaux chargés
d'accueillir ayad nous demandent de les
laisser seuls mais nous autoriserons
finalement à rencontrer d'autres enfants
l'allemagne est le premier pays
d'accueil des yézidie en europe
aujourd'hui le parlement régional à
stuttgart a invité des rescapés a
témoigné de leur martyr devant les
députés allemands à cause des sévices
atroces infligée par dash les yézidis
sont venus en allemagne et l'allemagne
les a accueillis
[Musique]
le chef d'orchestre de cette grand'messe
c'est le docteur michael blum fondateur
du programme qui accueillit ayad et
quelque 600 enfants avec leur maman pour
lui sauver ses enfants
c'est avant tout leur offrir un toit un
environnement sécurisé et leur permettre
de renouer avec une routine pendant
toute la première année du programme
nous n'avons pas entendu ces enfants
rire ni faire une blague dans leur pays
d'origine
il était comme de petits robots mais dès
qu'ils arrivent en allemagne ils
s'épanouissent et quand je leur demande
se battent ils ont envie ils répondent
un petit déjeuner est allé à l'école
vous pensez que c'est suffisant qui
n'ont pas besoin de suivi psychologique
ils n'ont pas besoin de thérapie à leur
arrivée il va juste une bonne éducation
et vivre tout simplement
ils ont aussi besoin de refaire
confiance à leur maire
car certains en veulent à leur mère de
ne pas avoir su les protéger ils doivent
retirer les liens avec leurs mamans
leurs frères leurs soeurs et ils doivent
le faire dans un environnement sécurisé
ils ne peuvent pas le faire dans un camp
ou sous une tente
le programme du docteur blue&me aurait
fait ses preuves
mais un retour à la vie normale est il
suffisant pour effacer le passé
comment appréhender la liberté pour ses
lionceaux dressé à tuer après
l'expérience de la guerre les enfants
subissent celle du déracinement des
cousins dyad sont arrivés ici il y a 6
mois ils vivent ta 100 km de stuttgart
en collectivité avec une trentaine
d'autres réfugiés la chambre ghayatt à
12 ans ouais ou dors tu ici gaillac a
été libérés des griffes des champs 2015
le voici en tenue de jihadiste
il a été soumis à un entraînement
militaire et à des cours de propagande
[Musique]
ça c'est mon cartable aujourd'hui
galliath apprend l'allemand pour pouvoir
aller à l'école
j'apprends l'allemand theo albrecht
piscine d'autres fois ça c'est bien ici
mais on n'est pas heureux dans cette
maison
tous semblent un peu désoeuvrés dans ce
petit village de la campagne allemande
peu d'encadrement aucun soutien
psychologique ni pour ghayatt ni pour
son grand frère
ragheb 15 ans l'adolescent a pourtant
été entraîné au redoutable quand al
farouq à jaca
[Musique]
il y est resté huit mois on le voit ici
aux côtés d'un djihadiste ragheb est
sorti ébranlé de cette épreuve et il
attendait beaucoup de son installation
en allemagne tu vois des psychologues
non et je ne suis pas content dans cette
maison on est les uns sur les autres
ici on touche une petite pension
mensuelle si on avait pu la toucher en
irak
on ne serait pas venu ici qu'est ce
qu'on trouve de plus ici rien au final
c'est la même chose
malgré une mensualité de 250 euros
des cours d'allemand et le soutien d'un
assistant social ragheb se sont livré à
lui-même pour se changer les idées
les deux frères se rendent parfois à
rottweil la ville la plus proche
ça me rend heureux cet endroit c'est
joli moi j'aime pas ici les gens sont
heureux alors que chez nous dice
occupent notre village est ici on est
des étrangers
pas facile d'oublier dèche même sur ce
marché de noël ghayatt et ragheb il
retrouve d'autres réfugiés
tous s'interrogent sur leur avenir dans
ce pays de la seconde chance ma famille
me manque
mon père et mes grands frères ils ont
été pris par des ch
mais ici je vais apprendre l'allemand
travailler dur pour devenir médecin ou
professeurs
[Musique]
pour les enfants du docteur blue et se
rêvait un avenir est déjà une première
victoire mais il est impossible de
savoir comment ils évolueront depuis le
tournage nous avons reçu des nouvelles
dyad il va bien et se dit heureux en
allemagne mais d'autres enfants reste à
sauver qui vivent toujours sous le joug
de dèche
c'est la mission que s'est donnée barad
le libérateur d'otages nous le
retrouvons au kurdistan pour une
opération d'exfiltration à haut risque
aujourd'hui il s'agit d'akram le frère
de zoumana
ça c'est akram on a déjà libéré sa soeur
qui a 6 ans akram doit arriver dans
quelques heures deux rakas avec d'autres
otages yézidie le réseau de bars zad a
dû les expliquerez du califat de la
syrie vers l'irak en passant par des
zones où s'affrontent des shs et les
forces kurdes
ce travail demande beaucoup de temps
leur lieu de détention et surveiller de
très près nous passeur doivent
déterminer la meilleure stratégie
d'exfiltration vers les zones libres
le danger est énorme bien sûr mais nous
on se doit de tout essayer pour sauver
le maximum de personnes
une longue attente commence par z est
rejoint par hassan un membre de son
réseau
akram a bien été libérés mais après son
long périple il est désormais interrogé
par une milice qui dit qui contrôle la
zone et exige d'entendre tous rescapés
en provenance du califat
finalement les ex-otages sont amenés
pour être rendus à leurs familles à
gauche une mère libérée avec ses deux
enfants à droite avec une milicienne
yézidie akram qu'aucune famille l'attend
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'est moi je t'ai eu plusieurs fois au
téléphone en secret on va les voir jouer
mana jo manoeuvre à jaca non joue mal
est avec nous en sécurité
[Musique]
il n'ya pas sa colère
arrêtez m'embrasser terme à ses péchés
non allez pêcher c'est fini c'était
avant c'est déjà ça bassam
apparemment ils ne veulent pas nous
laisser akram tout près du but se dresse
un obstacle de taille
les miliciens yazidi ne veulent remettre
l'enfant qu'à un membre de sa famille
mais les parents d'akram ont été tués
barzani tentent de les convaincre une
dernière fois la cram n'a plus de
famille reste que des cousins éloignés
du côté de son père mais la décision est
sans appel les combattants et zidi garde
de l'enfant
la grosse cote moi je suis ta grande
soeur tu vas devenir un homme
je vais t'emmener au marché pour acheter
des habits
non je veux rien la nuit tombe à cramer
finalement emmené par les miliciens nié
y dit elle aussi accusé d'entraîner des
enfants dans leur guerre contre neige
akram n'aura fait que changer de camp
[Musique]
dis leur camarade il va rester avec nous
où il va rester avec nous le temps qu'un
membre de sa famille vient la chercher
mais qui vont nous les camarades avec
les camarades et au revoir
tout juste sauvé a cramé de nouveau
happé par la guerre les enfants perdus
du califat n'ont pas fini de payer leur
lourd tribut
vous
ok
[Musique]